marlon brando pourquoi êtes-vous venu à
paris parce que je tapais le bambou pour
universel international company vous
avez déjà un long passé derrière vous
n'êtes vous pas fatigués de votre métier
nu du coin
tout entend tout le monde fatigue de
métier les jeux et je vais dans une
transe transition entre mon métier est
pas encore exactement trouver le métier
que je voudrais faire mais je crois que
quand je finis les films je vous dois
trouver quelque chose d'autre à faire
mais êtes vous quand même satisfait de
la tournure qu'a pris votre carrière
les tournées de la façon dont votre
carrière a marché on n'a jamais
satisfait dans la vie je crois toujours
là les dix points d'ici qu'on dit
maintenant dix points devant de la vie
et s'est divisé pour des rats où j'ai
tellement satisfait impossible
si vous faisiez mon métier quelle est la
question que vous vous poseriez oui je
crois c'est la même question que tout le
monde se demander n'importe
même si vous êtes alors qu'ils
fabriquent et le tapis sous le tableau
de temps en temps tout le monde il
pourquoi je faisais donc 60 mm
c'était dix ans très très très compliqué
nous n'avons pas le temps pour
poursuivre toutes les petites laborers
andy la mairie de subtilité
marlon brando pourquoi êtes-vous venu à
paris
et parce que je tapais le bambou pour
une force l international company vous
avez déjà un long passé derrière vous
n'êtes vous pas fatigués de votre métier
de temps en temps tout le monde fatigue
de métier les jeux et je vais dans une
transe transition entre mon métier n'est
pas encore exactement trouver le métier
que je voudrais faire
je compte quand je finis les films je
veux lui a trouvé quelque chose d'autre
à faire mais elle veut quand même
satisfait de la tournure qu'a pris votre
carrière de tourner et de la façon dont
votre carrière a marché on n'a jamais
satisfait dans la vie je crois toujours
là les 10 points le décès en vendée
département des suppléments dans la vie
et c'est difficile pour les rats où ils
ont satisfait à vos cv ou si vous
faisiez mon métier quelle est la
question que vous vous poseriez oui je
crois seulement une question qui tout le
monde se demandait une importante même
si vous êtes à la mouture qui fabrique
et le tapis ou le tableau de temps en
temps tout le monde il pourquoi je
faisais donc ça c'est le même cette
édition très très très compliqué nous
allons nous n'avons pas le temps pour
poursuivre toutes les petites la bhr1
andy la mairie de un smoothie vitae